okay it's about 833 here on the East
Coast Jim Warren is on your screen he's
in Chicago this morning mr. Warren we
started off this morning talking about
whether or not this is based on the
Economist magazine the event this
weekend is going to be an inspiring
event or whether it's going to be a
parody of democracy that being the vote
in Iraq what do you think it's going to
be well it could be a mix of the two
Brian and hi from a coal and windy
Chicago this morning I think for the
White House as they've now signaled any
vote is will be seen as a victory but I
think to a lot of folks around the world
particularly in the Middle East just got
off the phone with a friend in Gaza who
works for the United Nations this will
be seen as a put up as a sham
orchestrated by the United States I
think that's unfortunate
but I think that's the reality mr.
Hitchens no I mean I'm not gonna split
the difference it's extraordinary that
there's an election in Iraq if you run
into Iraqis around town which I have
done or hear from Iraqis by email and
Kurds as well which I do every day
practically haven't been there for a bit
but it's all the difference in the world
it's a night and day difference they
can't believe their their luck they
don't really they're having a say in the
future of their own country the fact
that it's being made so horrific ly
difficult by a Muslim Nazi mr. Abu Musa
knows as a car we who was imported into
a rug by Saddam Hussein before the
overthrow and is now the baptised if
that's the word for it it's the wrong
word obviously the anointed leader of al
Qaeda in the country has announced that
he's most against this election he's
against all elections on principle
elections he says a blasphemous and
profane a filthy Greek import into the
purity of the Muslim world well you
couldn't have it more plainly delineated
than that and I have no difficulty
choosing what side of the line
Jim worn a lot of our cars said well the
media is going to decide whether this is
a success or not
and you don't have to agree with that
but in your opinion what will people
have to say to make it a success I'm not
sure if the question is Brian what will
the media well like well let me let me
try to be more articulate I apologize
it's early adhere it when this when the
dust clears over the weekend and the
voting is finished what we'll have to
have happened to make it a success well
I mean for the White House and for folks
like my good friend Christopher with
whom I just flat disagree about this the
mere fact that one today is having for
instance in Rosemont Illinois and Skokie
Illinois folks going to the polls I
think in one of four or five places in
the US is a symbol of a clear
unequivocal victory I simply flat
disagree with Christopher goes I think
that the broad spectrum of historical
evidence suggests that social
transformation cannot be imposed by
external force for sure it can bring a
degree of order but the evolution from
the distinctly traumatized society that
Iraq was to one of stability and
coherence has to come from within and I
would just quibble and Christopher's
been there and I haven't I would just
quibble about how to interpret the
manifestations of what is going on now I
do not think they are ones necessarily
of a democratic culture I just simply
don't think those can be imposed by
external force when in when the
elections over who will be the leaders
that emerge in your opinion from what
you know can I just not be conceived as
if i duck
comrade Warren's challenge if Iraq had
been left to rot the way it was if the
Saddam Hussein regime would be allowed
to as it were collapsed naturally or
implode was actually what was happening
to Iraqis society then everything would
look like Fallujah by now
the people waiting in the wings were the
people like Zarqawi who were gonna try
and take over there was already in
existence an organization called the
feta he and Saddam conveniently named to
symbolize the fusion of baathism with
jihadism the would have been civil war
and it would have drawn in the
neighboring states opportunist
interventions from Turkey from Saudi
Arabia from Iran at the minimum there
would have been a nightmare black hole
that would be worse than Congo is now
the intervention that we made I think we
came to Latian was too little but it
saved us from very very very much worse
so it's I think it's precisely the
contrary of what Jim has said as with
the American Revolution in France
there's a certain minimum of force
that's needed before anyone is going to
pay attention if it wasn't for French
troops no one would ever fell of Thomas
Jefferson sorry to say but it's a brute
fact there with any other comparable
cases see what's your direct question if
the vote goes roughly as we think namely
if the if the Sistani list was a starry
backless winds and especially among the
Shia and if the Patra Union of Kurdistan
which is running in tandem with its
rival party will it be a very heavy
turnout in northern eruption also does
well I have been told that the the
nicest rumor I've heard from Baghdad
this week is that the shear will invite
Jalal Talabani the Kurdish needed to be
the president of Iran all the kurds are
sunni by the way well not all but most
do enough and then the the Prime
Minister might very well be offered
chalabi who said it's fantastic comeback
in the South has been campaigning very
well in company with Sunni politicians
by the way in sheer areas and who has
also good contacts with again he's a
possibility and then there are a number
of sunni figures who could be offered an
important place but the first thing that
the iraqis I'm talking to want to do if
they win is to show that they don't want
a transfer list sectarian regime now
this is extraordinary when you consider
the provocation they've been operating
under you could be killed just for being
Shia in Iraq
the moment mister misses a car we do not
and denounces the majority religion of
the Iraqis were not his
fellow-countrymen he's a Jordanian thug
in port and scum the phones shortly mr.
Warren what would your reaction be if
mr. Chawla we ended up as the Prime
Minister well I'd be I'd be rather
stunned particularly given the initial
influence we now see his distinctly
distorted view of what was going on his
and that of a and other members of what
might call a rocky diaspora had early on
particularly when it came to weapons of
mass destruction I think he's been
rather discredited but clearly had an
impact on a set of us actions which
resemble in some ways the huge mistake
of trying to flex our muscles and
exhibit imperial power in for instance
Somalia in 1992 Christopher's gonna
disagree but I think that the disarray
one sees now is a reflection of the
mistake of our initial unilateral action
I don't have a crystal ball
I hope it's calmed down in a year or two
from now I suspect it will not be why so
few Iraqis based in the United States of
something supposed to be had torn 50,000
of them eligible to vote and only 25,000
signed up and the figure I heard this
morning only 17,000 are gonna vote
it's very infuriating it seems to me the
the is it the International Organization
for Migration the IOM I can't give them
very high marks I mean I'm involved with
this quite a lot I know a lot of quite a
lot of Iraqis and Kurds I would have had
no idea if I was Nawrocki where to go
what to do and they were given almost no
notice and they have to travel in many
cases quite long distances and we know
that in in Detroit well actually
particularly in Dearborn Michigan listen
community and we know that the burns in
Nashville but the we don't have very
good idea of how spread out the Iraqi
diaspora isn't I don't think you know
anything like enough attempt was made to
find out still I mean that's to say I
mean if an Iraqi Jew actually came up to
me in New York recently after I've been
giving a
and said did I know how to help him get
registered and I said well I'll try but
you're starting with asking me he said
yeah I did know Houston again he's a
smart guy he didn't know so that's it's
a pity because I it's I think that a
four million Iraqi I saw so many of them
be living in democratic societies the
qualifications of all kinds we was
jurist hope in the long run as they have
the chance to go back they exercise
their right of return and this is if
this is a very shaky start to
reintegration Christopher Hitchens here
in Washington with us he's a graduate of
Oxford's Bailey old college ba and
philosophy politics and economics our
guest Jim Warren from New York City
originally is in Chicago where he's the
deputy managing editor of the Chicago
Tribune he is a graduate of Amherst we
go to Athens Ohio to start with you're
on the air yeah hi I was really shocked
to hear that Akhmed Chalabi was actually
a candidate I thought this guy is a fog
as far as what I've read and that he was
really wanted by the US government for
handing off fabricated intelligence to
the Office of Special plans and I want
to ask both these gentlemen whether they
will do their parts in doing more
investigative reporting about the group
of folks I guess who operated with the
way I understand it and read out of the
office of special plans giving you know
passing off this fabricated intelligence
that was passed then on to the American
public about the WMDs thanks Jim Warren
well personally I won't I've got a I've
got enough on my plate and I think the
paper and many other papers have done a
fair amount on mr. Chalabi obviously the
most vivid manifestation most sort of
controversial bit of reporting was done
by the New York Times and a reporter
there named Judith Miller who used
Chalabi apparently as a significant
force but I think Christopher has a
different view on him given a piece
Chris that I think you've posted on
slate.com a couple of days ago right
well the first thing to say of course is
that some the world weapons of master
we have not all of them were far we
don't know what New York is did with
what they declared that we couldn't
later fine but we're not it's not matter
of inventing them the Iraqis declared a
certain number they never gave an
account of what they've done with them
they're not allowed to destroy them
themselves by the terms of the UN
resolution that would be a very grave
breach of the resolution they have to
turn them over have them bagged tagged
and disposed of under international
supervision they didn't do that they
kept on with their posts in strategy of
concealment since then we have found
which the inspectors would never have
found the elements of a nuclear
centrifuge in the garden of dr. Mario
Bedi who led the American forces to
embed in his own garden he being
Saddam's chief nuclear physicist we have
found the evidence of Saddam Hussein
trying to buy missiles off the shelf
from North Korea as late as March 2003
days before the intervention going on to
the International black market that's
been partly exposed by the way by the
intervention as much as was the Libyan
and Pakistani Network exposed by the
intervention there's a great deal of
non-proliferation the good consequence
from from the invasion in other words
and then if you look at the dwarf report
was show you have to do you'll see
really alarming stuff about chemical and
biological warfare and the elements that
were discovered of it that's the first
thing second thing is the CIA which has
got everything wrong in a row from from
start to finish it made it a crude
attempt to frame up it shall be recently
as an Iranian spy certainly failed
he's pursuing a lawsuit in the United
States against the false charge against
him of embezzlement in Jordan I think he
might very well win that lawsuit and
he's gone by dint of extreme political
skill and courage to being very nearly
the public face of the ISA Stanley lists
Greenville South Carolina George Bush
supporter good morning good hi and what
do you have to say well you guess from
the Tribune made an interesting comment
at the beginning he sort of inferred
that the Iraqis need to do more if not
necessarily just overthrow their own
government without our help and that's
their role but you know you can't fight
a revolution anymore like we did back in
our days the weaponry was different now
you can't fight a tank you know you
can't go up against the government's
weaponry you need help from the outside
and that's what we're provide
and I think it's a little bit Oh
unrealistic for him and even naive to
assume that that's the current role in
this road we face people need our help
they we freed millions of Shiites
billions of Kurds from this guy who is
raping all the resources from the people
and sticking it in other people's
pockets and keeping all the oil
resources I think we've done a lot and I
think it's too naive to think that we
should have total peace in just a few
months of or a year or two of this
excursion I mean it took Europe decades
thanks Connor mr. Warren well again I
just think the broad spectrum historical
evidence suggests that you can't impose
social transformation by external force
I also think that well whereas I might
stipulate to some of Chris's chronology
of what Saddam was up to I think history
will suggest that he was in a far weaker
State then we realized but the evidence
of that was there it was reflected in
the increasing brutality it might have
led us to be a little bit more
imaginative in dealing with an array of
forces within the government and to try
somehow to patch up relations with the
broader world in particular via the UN
and have somehow a larger more
multilateral force there I think the way
it is now with just us history suggests
that's not going to work and when it
comes to you know how we treat
minorities I think particularly on a
week in which we're celebrating this the
60th anniversary of the liberation of
Auschwitz Chris mentioned the the Nazis
early on that one has to remember that
one big test of democracy is how it
treats its minorities and I think jury
is definitely out on what's going to
play out as far as that goes in Iraq
hold your thought mr. Hitchens let's get
Washington DC and here you're on the air
there were countless post-war blunders
or miscalculation by the Bush
administration likes to call them but
the CIA recently admitted that Iraq is
now a training ground for terrorists
so in Bush and Cheney say it's
better than our soldiers are fighting
the terrorists in Iraq than here at home
I wonder was that the administration's
plan all along to use our soldiers like
bait and wouldn't that be considered
treason and a war crime Jimmy I think
you misunderstood what the CIA may have
said I think I would decline the task of
interpreting CIA analysis for you there
is a common fallacy though and I'll make
I'll make a guess that I think you have
a share in it which is that terrorism is
produced by the resistance to it in
other words that have been wish we heard
when the intervention took place in
Afghanistan it'll be a quagmire it'll
turn the our world against us they are
straight and so unless you were hearing
now from the out street in Iraq and
people are still complaining about it
that if we fight them in Iraq they
literally make them angrier well this is
the same mistake as people made about
New York and Washington DC they thought
what have we done to make them do this
to us
you see what I mean that's the that's
the original error mr. czaka we was
correctly identified right in front of
the United Nations by name by Secretary
of State Colin Powell before the
intervention in Iraq took place now
think about it after September the 11th
Saudi Arabia and Pakistan started
expelling al-qaeda people pretending
they hadn't known them helping to round
him up in many cases there was no
country in the world that could have
before have anything to do with them
will be seen too but Iraq started to
invite them in from Afghanistan after
September 11 and mr. Sirko he was
brought to a rock Western I was saying
after certainly never know what
conclusion do you think is legitimate to
draw from that Fort McCoy Florida
invented this guy that we brought him on
no go ahead please a real quick question
the how is the Iraqi vote affecting
Europe given the large Muslim community
and one other thing mr. Hitchens long
time ago I spoke to you on the phone
through c-span and I
was talking about emotional politics
versus reasoning politics I said that
the definition of intellectual is
rational rather than emotional you said
I wonder what after I could offer what
dictionary is reading from the American
Heritage Dictionary of the English
language and you I just wanted to make
sure that I told you what dictionary I
read it from thank you very much
did he tell us which one I'm not sure he
did are you still there
it was I'm telling him that I he asked
after I got off he said I was dictionary
he's at the Heritage the definition it's
the what dictionary is this guy reading
from so I'm telling him the American her
okay I thought you I wonder if that was
really me it doesn't sound right so the
question over mr. Warren what about
Europe well I don't know tell me how
many folks are going to be voting there
I mean obviously a lot of what's gonna
be playing out in Iraq with the
elections and the aftermath will be seen
in a wider Europe through the lens of a
distinct anti-us hostility and I think
unfortunately here's where I probably
also part company with with Christopher
I think that's the way it will be seen
throughout the Middle East I think the
elections will be seen as an American
show I think they'll be seen as a sham
they'll be seen in Gaza and elsewhere
again through the lens of an
anti-american view and they will not
have the sort of cleansing irresistible
irretrievably cleansing and liberating
impact that the Bush administration
hopes so what's it going to take if if
you're right
you know they're going to write a
constitution and then have elections
later on in the year and all that at
what point would would the Europe or
anyplace else believe the this situation
if it turned out positively in Iraq well
at the point presumably that you'd have
all the the manifestations of a truly
democratic culture that was born from
within and not imposed I'm not going to
discount the possibility but I'll be
proven wrong I just think that that
history underscores that the virtue and
virtue
impossibility of imposing all this by
external force will there be folks in
Europe and elsewhere who will never buy
into the possible the possibility that
the pre-emptive invasion was a
masterstroke yeah I mean that's that's
the case but you know for millions
around Europe who are simply antagonized
per se by our actions I think most of
those will never be convinced no that's
probably true the one isn't going to
expect to get pressed and I'm just era
either but there have been notable
comments in our media print media by
influential commentators saying look the
only two elections that are happening in
our world present among the Palestinians
and in Iraq and both of these are so to
speak enabled by the United States or by
foreigners you know what does that make
us what can we what can we stack up
against that uh if you look at our own
internal politics in the Arab world
they're shambles in a disgrace
there's a lot of opinion of that sort
also to be found in the Lebanese press
which is fairly free well it's also got
to be a fantastic election I hope very
soon there's there's a good deal of
osmosis I would say about it throughout
the Arab world and I'm afraid that I
think you contradict yourself in terms
you cannot say that an election is being
imposed on people Unites States is not
forcing anybody to vote what it is is is
enabling them to do so this is a release
of Iraqi liberties from a previous very
hideous confinement by very menacing a
threatening regime it was a country that
was a prison on the surface and a mass
grave underneath it key partners and an
arsenal key partner Jersey go ahead
please I wanted to know if anybody
remembers that the United States had
helped from France and its revolution
and also to I wanted to know if anybody
wanted to comment on the economics for
the United States of how that the money
that's being spent there is going to
change the policies that were there
before as far as you know
them accepting France and Russians in
Germany money and is that going to
switch and change its warrant well I
mean presumably if this works out and
one has a freely constituted sovereign
independent government or you know a
string of governments no matter how
future elections go and some you know
clearly free-market economic system
perhaps then you know I'm sure all bids
for virtually anything will P will be
entertained so I wouldn't have much
doubt if this works out and we do
ultimately have a democratic culture
which is foster and one will also have a
democratic economic culture that is
fostered and you know whether it's you
know French aerospace or Russian oil
firms that you know a free market in
some form of capitalism could
conceivably conceivably flourish when
was the last time you were there some of
2004 so watch them yeah concrete for
that so Concord New Hampshire love your
book thank you it looks right it's like
this it's on my desk
here so you can see what would you mind
just waving it love poverty and more
journeys and essays Christopher Hitchens
brand-new out in late 2004 Concord go
ahead mr. Wardin I have a bone to pick
with you being a psychologist I think
they're sitting in a very defensive
position but I don't agree with you
about I don't agree about it the way
we're treated or the way we're held
respect or disrespect by Europe France
and Germany are loaded with Muslim
residents I don't think they wanted to
get involved with this because I didn't
want an uprising in their own countries
and I support what the president's done
I support our troops and I pray I hope
and pray that this election under the
aegis of the United States or under the
safe
under the troops and the safety that
they can provide god bless these Iraqis
who go to the polls that's my comment
thank you very much god bless well now
you've made me so unalterably
self-conscious here it's it's difficult
enough being in the presence of mr. lamb
and mr. Hitchens but now I think I'm
gonna have to change the positions of my
arms and legs
lest you be you'll be proven correct but
it appears you can't do that though
watching you right there you still have
your arms folded like that did you
realize you were in a defensive position
well well in in the present certainly of
of Christopher that just may be an
absolutely natural reaction and in the
presence I should say to you and your
viewers of someone who now has attained
even greater iconic cultural status as a
result of being rather specifically even
ostentatiously mentioned Tuesday night
on The WB program the Gilmore Girls for
your viewers out there who somehow
missed it
this favorite teenage show opened with a
scene in which I believe a Yale
undergrad was quite frustrated with her
inability to get through to c-span on a
caller line to voice her opinions about
Iran which is justice suggests Gilmore
Girls today perhaps Christopher and
Brian Desperate Housewives tomorrow so
Brian you you you better watch out
you're probably making me more defensive
but as far as the the substance of the
call I don't really think that German or
French reaction had anything to do with
any anxiety over internal you know
domestic disruptions as a potential
result of supporting the u.s. what's
this situation in France roughly how
many Arabs are there Muslims and what is
mr. Shreck really doing in your opinion
I think mr. shocks policy was that of a
clear and cello relationship between
yourself and Saddam Hussein went back a
long way was a family business I mean he
used to have who died because I who say
and to come and stay on their holidays
and
Paris he helped build Saddam Hussein a
nuclear reactor knowing what he wanted
it for very firm friends and a certain
money would have changed hands as well
because that's the way mr. Schirach does
business he had to run after all for the
presidency of France partly too well in
fact entirely to retain his immunity
from prosecution which he would have
faced otherwise further his many crimes
and depredations as mayor of Paris that
there's a pimp basically he would have
taken this view if there were no other
Muslims in France now as to how many of
them there are it was it's a very good
question it is officially thought to be
something like 10% but there are many
Muslims in France yes we should be six
men there's a lot but there are many I'm
trying to remember the name of the
French author he'll we've come might
come after in a second he said that
there are many Muslims in North Africa
fundamental Muslims who believe that the
figure figures much greater and you
think that France is already on the
verge of becoming a Muslim country they
refer to it sometimes as part of the dar
al-islam the house of Islam that's
wishful of course but it shows how some
wisdom is conceived of this as a sort of
demographic revolution Danbury
Connecticut good morning oh good morning
Brian
James Warren I'd like this question
addressed to him please Georgia yeah
James I'm wondering I heard Chris
Matthews mentioned this quite a few
months back before this Iraq thing at
all about we do not strike another
country because I know there's something
I don't know which flag it is but it's
always with the American flag a snake
coiled up which says don't tread on me
now what do we have doing having gone to
Iraq at anything at any point what does
how does that give us the Liberty to do
something like that and then you know
blame Saddam and all when he wasn't the
culprit for 9/11 and all how does this
all tie in and is there anything in the
constitution that could back this up
saying that you know Bush can be
impeached because of doing this that he
did go against this which is very
important don't tread on me which is
a symbol of the Americans and it's on
that flag I I asked the person that the
screen me he didn't know so so I don't
know which flag that is but I know it's
a snake it's very important would that
have any correlation and getting Bush
and Peach because of the action he took
which was certainly unjustified and
Brian may I ask you something
it's really I see all these magnets
support our troops and all well I just
found I went to a meeting and I found
where I could get a magnet bring the
troops home home now which I let back
slide and I didn't do it because of the
holidays and I'm getting two of them now
I was wondering and I won't do this but
I was going to ask you can I give this
number out in case anyone else wants to
cuz all I see a support our troops
support our troops
I'll give it out on the air if you'd
allow me go ahead thank you Brian it's
area code two one two which is New York
City eight six eight five five four or
five I'd like to see those on the cars
because I think it's high time that the
troops are brought home now because this
war was certainly unjustified and Bush
should have been impeached too long ago
Thanks you know if do you know what
she's talking about
yes it's it's an early flag of the
American Revolution and I think the
feeling was designed probably by
Benjamin Franklin it's a pretty
impressive looking water moccasin or
some kind of tough snake and it just
underneath says don't tread on me and
mr. Warner it was a very early colonial
revolution is living do you want to
respond to our caller on the subject of
a possible action against the president
I mean one perhaps could argue that if
mr. Hyde of Illinois and his merry band
could find it justified to bring
articles of impeachment against someone
for oral sex in
the white house that hey why not for
something like this but the practical
reality and political reality is there's
no chance in the world that it that it
would happen and as far as bringing the
troops home I think the I think the the
difficulty and in the position that some
folks like my have that like myself have
in in being very critical of the
invasion thinking it was wrongheaded
thinking that it will not attain the
goals that the Bush administration and
people like Christopher hope the problem
I have right now is ok so what do you do
do you bring them home now I think that
would be disastrous I think the the
double-edged sword that people like
myself in the face is that at this point
we can't afford to fail I personally
wish we could somehow convince a much
broader force via the UN to come in but
they seem to be shell-shocked for for a
bunch of reasons and nervous about
coming in seeing the escalating violence
but I think at this point the impact of
our pulling out would be disastrous Jim
Warren with the Chicago Tribune in
Chicago this morning and Christopher
Hitchens who writes for Vanity Fair and
slate.com here in our studios they'll
both be with us for another 55 minutes
Benton Arkansas you're on the air hello
yes sir I want to ask this ok now in
this plan of the Constitution that
they're going to draw is it going to
give right I mean what I mean is is it
going to allow the voice of Christianity
to be speaking of spoken freely the
voice of Muslims to be spoken freely the
vote the voice of Jewish people to be
spoken freely without the fear of being
killed
mr. Hitchens interesting question I mean
you you would hardly know from most of
the coverage of Iraq that I can't say
exactly it's between 3 and 4 percent of
Iraqis are Christians usually Nestorian
or Chaldean Christians of
ancient form of Catholicism and may well
be the oldest Christian community in the
world and certainly the earliest
biblical footprints has to be traced in
in Iraq and there's a tremendous
contribution made by Iraqi Christians to
the life and culture and architecture of
the country and many many respectives
Iraqi citizens there's been an attempt
recently to blow up their churches and
intimidate them trying to drive them out
of the country as was done to a very
large number of the Jewish people of
Iraq in 1947-48 as a kind of tit for tat
for the expulsion of the Palestinians by
the Israelis from their homes actually
94 71 more Jews in Baghdad than there
were in Jerusalem it was a very very old
center of of Jewish life now the the
draft constitution that Iraq was drawing
up before the terrible outbreak of
violence in the declaration of state of
emergency did have entrenched guarantees
for Christians yes and it was beginning
to discuss whether or not the Iraqi Jews
who'd been dispossessed and expelled
from the country would have the right of
return in fact that was one of the
things that began the aggression of
people like Machado solder and Abu Musab
al-zarqawi was there was exactly the the
claim that Crusaders and Jews were being
indulged by the by the new transitional
authorities so de Texas good morning Hey
and one thing I'm kind of new to
Washington watching a journal I'm glad I
was I didn't know anything about this
during the Clinton impeachment era I
want to defend mr. Warren on the lady
said that he added on phones that lady
he's in Chicago give him a break you
know I've been I agree with you a lot on
certain things and you know but you
think you've been like a people
Saddam Hussein and I know you gonna
Holloway try to kill and one thing about
it I was spending a trillion dollars in
losing thousands and thousands of
soldiers live we tell you know we are
leaning it's like poker you know once
you done calls and raised and you know
you can't hold you came folk cause y'all
in there
thank you gentlemen have a great Friday
mr. Warren there's your philosopher view
protecting you from Desoto Texas
it's a my my arms being folder clearly
an act of self-preservation amid the
meteorological onslaughts here today is
it really that cold out there no not for
us or and shouldn't be for a Hoosier
cable television host like yourself but
maybe all those years in the East have
have changes the blood a little thinner
now and I don't know before we move to
the next call I do want to bring up
something that mr. Hitchens might be
interested in and that is the series it
started on I'm not sure what day was it
January 19th
who knows before that 18th whatever day
it started on your series of Henry
Kissinger telephone call notes tell us
about that and where can people see them
well if you go to the National Archives
no but I mean where can they see yours
your stories oh well you could try to
navigate I guess our website Chicago
Tribune dot-com I think you'd have to
register and I'm not sure if the fact
that it's a week or two old may may mean
you have to pay a buck or two or go to
Nexus Lexus but it was a series which
ran last Monday through Friday there are
thousand thousands of pages of Kissinger
transcripts in most cases he had his
secretaries listening in unknown to the
caller and then in shorthand taking down
notes and then transcribing the
conversations mr. Kissinger no surprise
had no intent of these seeing the light
of day during his lifetime the initial
deed of gift to library Congress was
such that they would not appear until
five years
after his death that was litigated he
lost those are now all available and off
what I've seen I think they are to put
it mildly stunning as Chris knows
because he's been very solicitous to me
on this subject in the past I spent a
lot of time listening to Nixon phone
conversations and I think my first sense
in looking at hundreds of hundreds of
pages of Kissinger zone transcripts is
that they provide a much better much
more nuanced and not more in any way
flattering sense of the gentleman than
one receives in his phone conversations
which his boss mr. Nixon taped all those
years but last week the difficulty for
me was figuring out how for a daily
newspaper you divvied this stuff up so I
decided to open with a couple of parts
on the astonishingly depressingly
incestuous relationship that mr.
Kissinger turns out to have had with the
elite of the Washington media those
conversations are some of those
conversations with everyone from Joseph
Alsop to Barbara Walters ran last Monday
and Tuesday and then there was a part
related to a at the time very prominent
United States Senator from the state of
Illinois a moderate Republican who was a
dog during the Vietnam War and was much
disliked by Kissinger and Nixon now
Senator Charles Percy then I believe
last Thursday was what I considered
almost stomach-turning series of
conversations involving mr. Kissinger
and genocide in Pakistan in the year
1971 where the US government despite the
clear unequivocal warnings of its own
diplomatic staff in Dhaka turned the
other way because of practical pragmatic
considerations involving the then covert
and treaties to China which was using
the military dictator Yahya Khan general
Khan in Pakistan at the
I know Christopher has spent a lot of
time on rather unseemly aspects of mr.
Kissinger particularly involving the
overthrow of the IND regime but Chris
some of this stuff on Pakistan back in
said late 1770s may match that in some
ways and then finally I ended up with a
lighter arguably more frivolous set of
conversations mr. Kissinger clearly was
exceedingly attentive to the powers that
be in Hollywood there are lots of
conversations with those folks in in
advance of the coming to Washington of
the then head of the Soviet Union Leonid
Brezhnev his top priority it seemed was
to somehow find Brezhnev copies of u.s.
western movies including ones with John
Wayne dubbed in Russian so he was
working the phones to various bigshot
producers in Hollywood on our time
trying to find a westerns dubbed in
Russian so it was it's a grand buffet of
the life of Henry Kissinger that is
found on these transcripts which he did
not want us to see certainly not right
now go to Chicago Tribune comm to find
them we're talking with Jim Warren and
Christopher Hitchens Waldorf Maryland
thanks for waiting go ahead please my
name is Brian and active-duty Air Force
and I just have a couple of comments I
haven't been to Iraq yet but I know
Airmen soldiers and Marines that have
been there and I want to remind the lady
from wants to get the sticker about
bring the soldiers home or whatever that
all of us are volunteers and the
majority of servicemen and women that
are over there big majority we are proud
to be there this was a slam dunk as mr.
Tennant said we may have not found any
weapons of mass destruction but just
like mr. Hitchens said the president of
France
mr. Shrock
remember we he tried to to help Iraq
develop a nuclear power plant atomic
weapons have been around since what the
40s correct and what you have now is a
situation in Iraq where people just like
mr. Anson said people are coming across
the borders from Saudi Arabia and all
the other countries al Qaeda and and
Plus you have the leftovers from the
shot on the same regime and this is
gonna go down in history and it may not
it's not going to happen for more it's
not gonna happen next month but this is
gonna be a historic thing 25 years from
now President Bush is going to be looked
at as a great leader and I'm not very
political but I tell you one thing mr.
Warren there's plenty of real estate and
France Thanks
mr. Hitchens will George Bush go down as
a great leader in your opinion if if he
helps to evolve the formational birth of
something that could reasonably be
described as a Palestinian state which
we're going to find out very soon about
and if he adds this to the liberation of
Afghanistan and the stabilization of
Iraq and if he's able to negotiate some
kind of demilitarization agreement with
Iran yeah that's that would be a
historic presidency same thing and it's
within his it's within his cross but
it's it's possible it's thinkable that
he could do that Chicago you're on
Chicago are you there now for some
reason now that we had a crossed line
LaSalle Michigan your on LaSalle
Michigan are you there please go ahead
LaSalle Michigan hello hello you're on
the air sir please go ahead
thank you I'm sorry where did I wasn't
hearing you and so there's something
going on downstairs go ahead
- mr. Warren I'm sorry there - uh to
gang up on you here mr. Warren you
mentioned a little while in this a
little while ago in this segment that
you know the bemoaning the fact that we
didn't get enough cooperation from our
allies and the United Nations and we now
know that the French the Russians the
Germans were all in cahoots with Saddam
Hussein under the auspices of the
oil-for-food program making fortunes
making untold amount of money one of the
people of Iraq we're being we're
suffering and and being essentially
ripped off from the money that was
supposed to benefit them now this is
what mystifies me about the American
news media um there's no way that a
Republican president in my opinion can
win with you guys no matter what he does
he's damned if he does and he's damned
if he doesn't and the oil-for-food
program is not being investigated by
people like you in this country and it's
it's probably one of the biggest scams
that has ever been perpetrated on people
in the history of this planet
thanks mr. Warren well first of all as
far as sort of being dogmatically
dogmatic and the president being damned
if he does are damned if he doesn't buy
that that's supposedly evil liberal
media elite which I suppose en't working
for a newspaper that has not endorsed a
Democrat for president since Horace
Greeley ran let me just say that I agree
with Christopher's analysis about how
Bush will be looked at in history if
he's able to pull some of these things
off particularly a Palestinian state as
far as the oil-for-food program I think
the the caller's rendition is a distinct
caricature that has been fostered by
folks on the political right
and the law many of the facile United
Nations bashers the absolute unequivocal
reality of that program is that of all
the thousands and thousands and
thousands of contracts that were signed
and approved every single one of those
contracts were inspected by two members
in particular the UN Security Council
Great Britain and more than Great
Britain the United States we know every
we knew every single thing that was
going on with that oil-for-food program
so to sort of suggest that this was
something run amok and we didn't know
about anything we had our reasons for
looking askance at what undoubtedly was
some level of corruption but they would
still have to do I think a fair amount
of analysis we'll see what mr. Volker
the former Treasury secretary says about
all that but sort of lost in this is the
United Nations the US government's
complicity in in the program there were
if there were unseemly matters that went
on if there were folks getting you know
oil in ambiguous of fashion you better
believe it that we knew about it well
well who is the we there I didn't you
didn't well we said mostly and it
doesn't sound as if from what you say
could have known either I mean the fact
that it's a very widespread scandal with
a great deal of complicity doesn't it
seems to me minimize it as maximize it
and remember that we're talking about
very important elements here while Iraq
was being starved and and beggared and
there is intermediate clients are being
enriched an underclass has been created
in a row something they hadn't had
before sort of lump and miserable starve
frightened uneducated layer of people of
course who are now in many ways the the
the easy prey for the for the fanatics
the the cause of much of the were of the
country I mean this is really important
stuff we're talking about there's 12
years thrown away of Iraqi life and
history and poisoned
which we're now having to clean up the I
think probably the worst element of
American foreign policy was the period
when it had sanctions plus Saddam
Hussein Millinocket main good morning
for Christopher Hitchens and James
Warren you're on the air here and I just
wanted to make a comment that the man
that you called up recently about it's
an all-volunteer army and that he was
speaking for everybody I just was
wondering that if he thinks that there's
gonna be really a better outcomes
now that we're in Iraq and that if they
think that the government is gonna be a
legitimate government that's what my
only question I think he's tuned in a
bit late I think we've done that god am
i doing it again let's go to Bowie
Maryland then I'm sorry go ahead boy
thank you and I appreciate the
discussion this morning I wanted to say
that I understand mr. Warren's point
about history not bearing out the
ability to impose democracy from outside
but I was wondering how he might
reconcile that with world war two and
what was done with Germany and Japan
which clearly weren't my democracies
before we went to war with them and and
maybe if mr. Hitchens can provide some
perspective on that as well at
appreciate it what I really say okay you
good question no go ahead press well I
had already said that the name of Thomas
Jefferson would never have been heard if
it wasn't for the French military
intervention in in the war in North
America so just that for start you you
make it perfectly good point noticed
about Germany in Japan but also most of
the countries of Eastern and Central
Europe redeemed from fascism by force I
can't actually think it's very many
cases where there's been democracy
without some kind of foreign
intervention precipitating or enabling
it so you'll push you to the opened door
with me mr. Warren I just think apples
and oranges
preemptive invasion versus the
incursions and various other nations by
Adolf Hitler I I don't think it's an
apples
two apples comparison miles Honeycutt of
Alexandria Virginia will the news media
lead with the death toll on January 30th
or the voting percentage will it be 20
dead in Iraq as Iraq votes or will it be
Iraq votes with 10 million votes and
with violence of 20 million dead who
decides with the media to run with
freedom first or with death mr. Warren
interesting question I think we we may
cop out and go with what we in the
newspaper business call the
double-barrel lead so I think we could
have an amalgam of the two but I do not
doubt that high up in those stories no
later then a second graph will be the
death toll if there is one Hudson
Florida good morning yes sir good
morning gentlemen my belief that this
war it I mean this election will be an
American sham and I believe that route
calls for this war was the oil and it's
still the oil if America was really
interested or George Bush was really
interested in human rights we'd be doing
something in Saudi Arabia which is one
of the most repressive regimes in the
world Colin let me ask you a question we
don't get that much oil out of Iraq so
what how do you figure on this well
because it's control most of the known
oil resources in the world are right
there in so you think it's a future
decision you think I mean you think it's
a calculated decision inside the White
House to go for the future correct is it
for personal is it for personal reasons
or for political reasons both both so
the people that are money and money is
power and I don't think human rights has
anything to do with it or very little to
do with it because if it if it did then
we wouldn't support people like Saudi
Arabia and Egypt I mean what are we
gonna set up and in Iraq go back go back
to your go back to your premise though
about the personal and power
do you think that people that run the
country sit around and say if we make a
move and spend two hundred three hundred
billion dollars over in Iraq we will
benefit our pocketbooks will get fatter
is that the way it works well I think
there that's the primary motivation not
not only personal but we want America to
have that oil to control that oil
thanks mr. Hitchens you start oh god
well if you want to our blood for oil
that would be the UN oil-for-food
program I suppose I mean I've got a
slightly tired of this of moveon.org
type argument there is a reply there
that would take into account what you
think is the double standard it's true
that the president has never used the
word Saudi Arabia in any critical sense
he's never mentioned it for example in
the same sense as the word terrorism
though it's known that the Saudis have
been the source of a huge amount of the
funding and encouragement and training
of them bin Laden is type forces around
the world however that can't be
associated announced publicly removing
Saddam Hussein was a form of putting the
Saudis in their place masari's if you
remember we're very opposed to this
operation they wouldn't let American
soil be used for it American forces
sentry moved to Gaza in order to shape
art in the liberation of Iraq
and if if Iraq's oil industry is
recuperated which we very much hope it
will be for the sake of the Iraqi people
it'll be quite a blow to Iraq's excuse
me to Saudi Arabia's existing monopoly
in the region which is why I think
there's a some covert Saudi hand in some
of this subversion in Iraq at the moment
because they certainly don't want to see
a Shia democracy on their border
actually don't want any cop democracy on
their border but preferably not a shear
one because the the much explosion
workers in the oil fields of Saudi
Arabia tend to be Shia Muslims
doubly discriminated against so they
have every interest in seeing this
outcome fail thus it is absurd of you
suggest that a oil policy an oil driven
policy in Iraq is also motivated by
Saudi interest when in fact if you
really thought about politics of oil
which you haven't done you'd see that
the reverse was the case mr. Warren do
you have anything to add well it's a
pretty interesting piece in the
january/february issue the current issue
of foreign affairs magazine an array of
articles on the Middle East one by
Dennis Ross the fairly well-known chief
middle-eastern troubleshooter during the
Clinton era guy who I think by his
admission met something like five
hundred times with the Yasser Arafat and
it underscores the I think the quote
desk the obvious that is securing the
flow of Middle Eastern oil has always
been remains a central tenet central
priority of US foreign policy was that
the reason the bush regime went into
Iraq I don't think so I don't know
whether either one of you gentlemen saw
this but I thought it might get an
interesting comment from either one of
you the president met with the New York
Times yesterday and it says here but
even while acknowledging that Iraq is at
a pivotal point in its history mr. Bush
appeared far more relaxed than he was in
August when he was last interviewed by
The Times and that was somewhere in New
Mexico he laughed when I asked about his
admission on Wednesday during a news
conference that he had not read the
article in the periodical foreign
affairs written in 2000 by Condoleezza
Rice they his new Secretary of State
laying out his foreign policy quote I
don't think Isis I don't know what you
think the world is like but a lot of
people don't sit around reading Foreign
Affairs he said chuckling I know this is
shocking to you are you surprised about
that mr. Warren given the circulation of
foreign affairs no I'm not
and but I mean it's interesting to get
those characterizations of sort of the
new more relaxed Bush and why shouldn't
he be
he's got job certitude for another four
years he's convinced that he is on a
mission his I think often troubling
level of moral certitude
is verging on stratospheric Heights post
victory over mr. Kerry so and he's got a
in theory a rather faithful Congress
we'll see what happens over the next
four years so he should be relaxed even
when he enters the den of the evil
Eastern liberal establishment press at
the New York time minutes to go Atlanta
good morning Atlanta good morning lived
warned yes sir hi hello please go ahead
sir earlier in the program I heard I
believe that I heard you say that Saddam
was a lot weaker than many people
imagined and I wondered if your your
implication was that he was about to
fall from within or there was a
possibility of that happening because if
if that if that's what you said it's the
first time I've heard it and thanks
caller follows no I'm not yeah no I'm
not I'm not sure that that would be the
first time I mean we'll have to see a
few years down the road but it's my
sense that we may conclude that the
obvious increase brutality that he was
exhibiting toward his own people was a
decided a sign of weakness and that we
should have somehow worked with an array
of internal processes within rather than
unilaterally invade as I said I think we
fell victim to the same mistake that we
demonstrated in Somalia back in 92 we
were talking earlier about mister
Warren's articles are and the Henry
Kissinger notes on the phone calls did
you write a book about Henry Kissinger I
did what was the title of it it was cool
the trial of Henry Kissinger and there
was a movie that came out and it was
made into a documentary which is cool
the trials just for there is no very
sacred variety it's the case for
enticing Henry Kissinger for crimes
against humanity and war crimes reason
I'm just looking at transcript one of
the reasons this intrigues me is because
there's the niece of the man that
Richard Nixon and Henry Kissinger
talking about works at this network and
I
if she's ever seen this a fellow named
Charles Collingwood I used to be at CBS
our own Eloise Collingwood oh it's nice
yeah
but anyway I'll just read you here this
was a you haven't you're your article
later that evening at 10:05 Kissinger
spoke with Nixon Kissinger I think it
went extremely well they're talking
about a speech the president gave about
Vietnam I think it was a most effective
speech I thought Network commentaries
went very well NBC and ABC were good CBS
I just caught pieces of it but
Collingwood and then he has it then he
runs off president Collingwood what was
he doing Kissinger he said Hanoi said
there must be a political settlement
before a ceasefire president calling
what is a communist he is married to
that pretty wife very left he is no damn
good what do you think of my doing what
do you think of my doing low-key
delivery he was moved right into that is
that typical of anything you've heard
before no it's it's a lot more laid-back
and what you tend to get from there's a
hideous telephone conversation between
Kissinger and Nixon on the eve of the
invasion of Cambodia
the illegal secretly planned invasion of
Cambodia Nixon is hideously drunk and
he's in I think in Key Biscayne with
with baby Roberta the Secretary of State
and the sector defense then I think mr.
Laird and mr. Schlesinger would have
been our post invasion of Cambodia so
kissing his backing Nixon as national
security adviser and I think he's hoping
obviously for mr. Laird's job as well
like sues mr. sledge his job but it's
he's it's risky he's he's helping the
secret war within the White House and
and the Drunken Nixon so swearing recess
to kiss him on the face if this doesn't
work out Henry it's your ass and you
have these two hideous thugs about to
complete the destruction of a neutral
country in Asia and you know just as
sordid as anything could possibly be we
need to go back to the phones we'll get
back to this in a minute mr. Warren
let's go to Newark New Jersey good
morning yeah hi yes my first time I'm
calling I'm familiar with mr.
Jen's work I saw the film about
Kissinger my question I guess kind of to
part I think what's been over-emphasised
in the media is the word democracy and I
think what's under emphasized is oil I
mean there are 29 countries today where
they don't allow religious freedoms it
was mentioned earlier about Saudi Arabia
Egypt for example Singapore if you're
caught with 500 grams of marijuana
you're hung
Java's witnesses are attained and thrown
in jail for 10 years
so obviously there was a there must have
been a factor that Iraq was chosen to
bring so called freedom freedom
so-called democracy and obviously it was
oil because I mean when Nixon ended the
gold standard in the early 70s supply
and demand is the name of the game the
biggest demand whoever controls the
biggest a man controls the world economy
and one of the biggest demands on earth
today is oil
now the word that's over emphasized in
the media is democracy
I know mr. Hitchens is a philosopher
does he really think that democracy has
ever existed isn't it United States more
like a nation of wage slavery
I don't feel free at all I lived here my
whole life isn't it like a system of
economic tater ships let me start with
mr. warm will come back to you on that
you you heard the call what about
democracy in this country mr. Warren
well I think it's in rather good shape a
unfortunate degree of economic
inequality aside and as far as the the
claim of something like 29 countries
where there's not much religious
tolerance I suspect it's it's much much
higher the the status quo in most places
is lack of democracy lack of religious
tolerance of any sort again I take the
president its word we went in before
this morphed into a humanitarian aid
mission we went in there to rid Iraq of
weapons of mass destruction and though I
do think that securing Middle East oil
has been a central priority
u.s. foreign policy on this one I don't
think it was the number one reason we
went in well to say the United States
was a democracy in the sense of the
people ruling would would perhaps be too
flat for it somewhat I mean in the
building that you can see behind us a
fairly small number of special interests
can most times out vote millions and
millions of voters but and that's
notorious but I think he would have to
say in those states that it was a
remarkably open and pluralistic society
where the expression of all opinions and
the and the coexistence of very great
diversity is very striking especially to
an immigrant myself and with a
considerable respect for the law so not
bad I think the motive for the
liberation of Iraq was much more
political than economic it was I think
very necessary to do something to alter
the balance of power in the region and
there was in any case and unpersuadable
appointment with the Keystone State of
that region Iraq just right between
Saudi Arabia and Iran that we had since
1992 when the close of the water
expelled Saddam Hussein from Kuwait
we had appeared through President Bush
Senior to promised the Iraqis that if
they rose against that I was saying we
would support them when they did we did
not so we had incurred a debt and we
were also keeping Iraq under
international sanctions which was
something of a mutation of its
sovereignty and we had adopted Iraq ever
since already as a responsibility the
real Jim keeps recurring to 1992 in
Somalia really what one should refer to
is 1992 and the failure to remove that I
was saying in in good and sufficient
time we would now be 15 years intonation
building and democracy in Iraq if we had
not backed off that crucial
responsibility at that time speaking of
a few years for the Lukas speaking of
being an immigrant
when will you raise your hand to pledge
allegiance to the United States of
America it'll be in your state I go
there because I've my paperwork is in
the system I'm somewhere
Homeland Security and if you plan DC
you're deemed to apply it in Virginia
so I'm every dude in Charlottesville I
mean and if I can if can I add something
as you know as a child of Austrian and
German immigrants in the case of my
Austrian mom someone who fled Hitler as
he was after he had moved into
Czechoslovakian was about to come in to
Austria and something that bothers me
about the last caller there is a certain
growing sort of conventional wisdom in
the form of a certain angst when it
comes to describing the current state of
American media in the building right
there with you guys at 400 North Capitol
in Washington DC you have several other
news channels MSNBC and most
particularly the currently ascendant
news channel Fox and there's all this
trepidation about increasing numbers of
ideologically driven news outlets I mean
I tend to find this rather south first
rather salutary and ultimately a sort of
back to the future example a throwback
to days when there were 50 60 70 years
ago in cities like Chicago there's 6 7 8
9 newspapers I think the homogeneous
Asian and centralization of media which
we have seen over the last 40 50 years
has not been particularly wholesome and
I think what is playing out also with
the Internet is generally you know a
healthy manifestation in the turn of the
media though I don't buy into a lot of
the slobbering over the Internet and the
the the cries of joy over the old
traditional gatekeepers like the Tribune
in New York Times and CBS News now being
demolished because I think there's a lot
of unadulterated crap that one tends to
find on the on the internet too but it's
just a way to say to the caller that I
think his is a rather caricatured notion
of this country and there's degree
perhaps of increasing pluralism
especially when it comes to you know
folks like Chris and me and others
giving our two cents on an array of
outlets and I think that's again really
quite salutary sour Lake Texas you're on
the air
thank you very much for c-span and thank
you James Warren and Christopher
Hitchens
I wanted to particularly compliment
Christopher Hitchens and tell him I will
certainly go out and buy his book and I
appreciate so much his scholarship and
his analogy of events and my question is
given the majority voter registration in
Iraq of the Shias once the election
takes place
would you please comment on how you
think the protection of the minorities
will go forward Thanks yeah well we
touched on this earlier I hope others
who may have noticed that won't will
forgive me if I repeat myself a little
bit but the contents that I have at any
rate with the Iraqi National Congress
and the and the Shia so-called sheer
list lead me to think that they're very
well aware that there's a danger of them
winning too big if you're right and they
don't want to seem like a triumphalist
or a sectarian party they've made
considerable efforts to reach out as the
saying goes to those Sunni politicians
who are willing to have a dialogue and
their relationship with the Kurdish
minority in the north is very warm and
very good and remember that the Kurds
are largely Sunni and that there are
million Kurds in Baghdad as well as many
in the north
I mean the thing I think it's worth
bearing in mind is this when the press
says to you as it does every day the
rock is divided between the Sunni the
Shia and the Kurds that that's not
really comparing like with like I mean
the Kurds are not Arabs but they are
Sunni for example and it's a bit like in
Bosnia the press used to say it was the
Serbs the Croats and the Muslims once
again only giving one one people their
religion beware of this I would I've
never met an Iraqi who can't boast of if
he's a Sunni himself of a Shia
brother-in-law say or cousin or perhaps
a Kurdish uncle it's very much more
common than otherwise and especially in
the cities for that to be the case this
isn't a very hard and fast the
discrimination in other words and this
there's some reason for optimism that
people can get over it and think like
Iraqis and think like Democrats
anyway the main point is that arson
don't sound starry-eyed about it they
have the chance to do that now
politics is back in Iraq everything can
be discussed and that I think is is so
worthwhile
that I'm surprised by how much easy
cynicism there is about it Christopher
Hitchens is at our table in Washington
and James Warren is in Chicago and we're
the this program this morning we're
mixing and matching of different issues
here including these transcripts that
mr. Warren published this one on January
the 18th it's a discussion between
Barbara Walters and Henry Kissinger and
I wonder I'm going to read a little bit
I just wonder it this was in 1973 and
you say that here NBC's Barbara Walters
she's now with ABC speaks to Kissinger
about the parameters of an on-camera
interview she definitely wants for
competitive reasons and here's what
reads is it Walters
when will I hear from you Kissinger are
you home tonight Walters I'm
out to dinner and I'll be home later
this evening Kissinger see consumed by
jealousy Walters I know the real reason
I want to do this interview is just to
have a few moments with you alone
Barbara Walters Kissinger oh I knew that
with with a camera you you like warrior
isn't he meant
I guess Boyer isn't it's an accent thing
Barbara Walters should I call you when I
come home or will you be sleeping
Kissinger later in the conversation now
you know I'm going to be sitting there
waiting Walters you're so full of
baloney how could you be so marvelous so
fantastic so interesting so brilliant
and so full of that's the first question
I'm going to ask you Kissinger oh if you
complete the sentence Walters laughter
I'm glad you're back Kissinger Thank You
Barbara
is this kind of stuff normal love
between is it I mean it's you can't eat
enough to vomit enough Hritik anyway the
thing like that it's the the the the the
really relative element of writing about
kissing yeah well one of them one of the
variable was the absolute falling and
groveling that he got from my so-called
profession I mean Ted Ted Koppel would
have him on Nightline not as a
controversial person to talk with but as
the independent arbiter of everyone
else's and consultant everyone else's
conversations he has a column in the Los
Angeles Times it's syndication in the
Washington Post isn't worth the paper
it's printed on but he always gets his
side of the story printed in the New
York Times always dionyza by people like
la Walters just really awful mister
groveling do you feel that strongly mr.
Warne there's nobody here to defend mr.
Kissinger so well some of this stuff
particularly with the likes of Walters
verges on soft porn simple as that if
you have a chance Christopher
some of the you know fabled rich
journalists of the day of 50 60 s and
70s show up in these chats I think Henry
Brand several and there there's one
conversation
Brian was on by last Monday and Tuesday
I can remember
Brandon but again it's a very prominent
Brit journalist of the time and
Kissinger calls to see if he can borrow
his swimming pool that weekend as simple
as that and the and the instant answer
is what we would have expected of course
come over and bring Nancy his
then-girlfriend later wife Nancy
Mackenzie Laurel Brandon who was a
terrible toady and fauna I think was
very shocked to find that hadn't stopped
kissing or bugging his chin effect so
even while his boots have been licked by
these people he was doing them bad turns
Boston Mass thanks for waiting
hello my name is Joe I'm calling from
Boston I have a couple of minor comments
and then a question for mr. Warren first
of all I I guess I please don't cut me
up I've got so much and I'll try to be
brief first of all there isn't a person
that I know including myself that
believed for one minute that Iraq was a
possess weapons of mass destruction and
B had any links at all with al-qaeda I
believe with all my research and
information and knowledge of history
that that this was a sham from start to
finish and the the prospect that was put
forth that George Bush will go down in
history as a anything other than the
single president that almost demolished
domestic policy as well as international
relationships and at the end of the day
he will be accredited with dividing our
friends and uniting our enemies and the
question for mr. Warren that I'd like to
pull is if I could is what is your
reaction to the ongoing onslaught by the
right-wing media that somehow the
liberal press is in control of the
message in this country if you could
address that please I would appreciate
it mr. Warren well it's part of a much
longer discussion I I think it's
grotesque caricature though I'll be the
first to admit that on a range of issues
of permit of action
the death penalty abortion that in a lot
of our elite newsrooms you will tend to
find a distinct degree of consensus I
think on a day to day basis that is not
reflected in the vast majority of work
that we all do at paper like the Chicago
Tribune you know where were out covering
fires County Board meetings just sort of
all those run-of-the-mill important
things in people's lives I have a hard
time seeing how some of the likelihood
that one of our folks voted for Kerry
impacts all of that has there been a
similar consensus on certain issues
among the broadcast networks yeah I
think there has been but what I find a
greater reality is what has been
generally sort of a lack of diversity of
opinion I mean if you take a look at
what Christopher knows far better than
any of us you know the definitions of
the left in in Europe we're sort of
poverty-stricken one of the things I
still laugh at is when one looks at the
some of these shout fest shows on
television those folks who are sort of
characterized as lefties certainly by
European and many other criteria they
would be at best you know sort of
centrist to right so again I think it's
a far more complicated matter I think
the caricature nevertheless has sort of
taken hold of this elite liberal media
and I think we're all victimized by it
everything bad it's good at Rogers
Arkansas you're on the air
well hello hi hi Brian
you know it's been marvelous study to
observe mr. Hitchens views evolved over
the years and it's been wonderful so why
don't people that don't get stuck in a
philosophical or political rut it's
marvelous and I you know I must say that
I'm in great an agreement with most of
what he says and I don't tell it comes
to mother Teresa and Israel but that
said you know I admire his intelligence
in erudition but I I I just like to put
this to you Chris
as a proposition and if you just find
some historical Fault in what I say okay
I mean email me I am daddy old 45 at
yahoo.com I Oh Yahoo if you can't get it
all said no because I'd love to carry on
this conversation with you
here's the proposition Britain should
return Ulster to the Irish the United
States should return Mexico Texas to
Mexico and then Israel should return the
West Bank to the Palestinian thanks
first thanks for all this kind words
seconds I can't object if you say that
I'm evolving I so hope we all are but in
fact I don't think my position on Iraq
has changed at all I've for many many
years been a friend of the Iraqis and
Kurds who were struggling to remove the
regime of Saddam Hussein it's everything
that I do comes out of a sense of
solidarity with those people most of
whom actually have left just background
so did when I knew them so just as a
point I think that the partition of
Ireland was a very serious mistake and
it's being it's being very slowly and
put back together again and very
gradually demographically actually the
the the Protestant unionist population
of the six counties of the nine counties
of Ulster they were partitioned is
becoming minority within even the the
partition bit but there's no way that
meanwhile just to give Ulster back
because if there is a large a larger
population that simply rejects the idea
of quitting the United Kingdom I think
you'd find an even larger number of
people in Texas who would not want to
come under Mexican rule that would
include also I think a very large number
this Hispanic Jackson's your comparison
with the state of affairs and Palestine
is therefore completely and exact I mean
the
the Texans are not recent settlers
there's no original injustice John by
way of mass expulsion and the world's
come to recognize that the Palestinians
who liveth under occupation or in exile
or in dispossession I do have a claim to
a state of their own
and I hope you wouldn't want to argue
against that elementary no justice seven
minutes to go Boston Massachusetts John
there can you work on that or we're
going to have to pass yes please go
ahead
elections concerned how many actual
Iraqi security forces are going to be
able to secure polling stations and to
1988 okay fine do you know anything
about the security forces mr. Warren how
many there are no no I don't other than
you know I think there's even concession
on the part of the Bush administration
that we have you know not been terribly
efficient and effective in training
those folks I think no matter how one
looks back on the pre-emptive invasion I
mean I think there even some diehards in
the Bush administration who will concede
or at least conceded to me that the
disbanding of the Iraqi army was a huge
tactical mistake have you bet you've
been to hell lobbed you haven't you
you survived yeah I love just the town
in northern Iraq and Iraqi Kurdistan
it's quite near the Iranian border which
was destroyed by chemical weapons after
the iran-iraq
war as were approximately 400 other
Kurdish villages destroyed or evacuated
and usually accompanying this with the
excuse me I shouldn't say evacuated I
mean subject to mass expulsion and
deportation many many many tens of
thousands of Kurds are still missing
from that period there occasionally they
turn up in in mass graves I think it
does qualify as a genocide because we
have from the captured documents of the
Iraqi Baath Party a reason to conclude
the the campaign that they call the
Anfal campaign was a real attempt to
remove erase that the Kurdish population
of northern Iraq so it would meet the
standard of prosecution under under the
Genocide Convention last call point
raised California you're on the air both
of you to come in a little bit more on
the original mistake that I heard you
both actually mentioned I did the actual
bat-channel work between Saddam's
government and the US State Department
and Saddam was being offered
normalization that he would get rid of
his weapons of mass destruction and
according to mr. blixxy had mr. Blix in
fact called mr. Bush a bastard for
invading when he did and I would present
to you that the original mistake is
allowing Israel firsters into our
policymaking process and using our
American government to create the
greater Israel using our American
government and our American men and our
money to create this greater Israel so
you really believe that this Iraqi
election will be accepted if it goes
forward I just thought of something I
meant to say to Daddy o45 which is that
if you like or don't like my stuff
another freezer you still might like the
chapter I have in my book about
testifying before the Vatican against
her sainthood cause you may think that's
not much of an answer to the previous
gentleman but I think unless you give us
your names we've no right to assume that
you were involved in any back-channel
ago she Asians between the this the
United States government and Saddam
Hussein's let me ask you on there's a
rather quick change of subject to the
Jewish Question I thought something
shady but let me ask you both about the
Israeli Constitution what you know about
it is it can you know we're talking
about democracy in Iraq is it wide open
in Israel that anybody that goes there
goes has they have freedom of speech can
they participate in the system can they
become citizens and well suddenly if
they're Jewish
and if they qualify under the law of
return but they have to be Jewish well
you could be a citizen of Israel in two
ways one one is like me to have a Jewish
mother and you can go and claim all the
rights of an Australian citizen straight
away which yes I'm doing through most of
the constitutional protections that we
mean by democracy there's a very great
deal of pluralism for Jews in Israel the
other way of doing it is to be one of
the Arab citizens who avoided being
thrown out in 1947 or 48 who were made
into into Israeli citizens and who have
seats allotted to them in the Knesset
mr. Warren I want to give you a chance
on that one anything you want to comment
on the Israeli thing
no I concur with with Christopher and
this is my final chance to say anything
I just want to tell you and your viewers
I hope you're not too modest in future
days about the fact of your increasing
cultural iconic status and having it
made it having made it into the script
of the Gilmore Girls the other night
Brian I hope this results in a
precipitous increase in the number of
female teenage viewers and listeners to
the Washington journal I think the only
issue here Lauren is appreciate you
mentioning that Gilmore Girls but what
were you doing watching the Gilmore
Girls we have a financial interest we
own the WB along with Time Warner and
given the state of the tribune stock
right now which has been going south
anything I can do to boost those WB
ratings even watching the Gilmore Girls
I shall do thank you very much mr.
Warren for joining us in Chicago this
morning and mr. Hitchens
I asked you earlier and I think mr.
Warren stepped on your lines you're
going to become a citizen in the year
2005 in Charlottesville
well I don't know how long it'll take
for Homeland Security to get round to me
I mean there's a big backlog now for
citizenship applications but I'm in the
system somewhere
and yes I'm deemed to have applied in
Virginia and if my book on Thomas
Jefferson will come out this year in May
I think and my dream has always been to
take the earth Charlottesville we've got
to go live I thank you we've got to go
live to the Senate Democratic only
policy committee and